back in the Watergate days back in the
olden days what they said is okay who
knew what when so that's my question
about Wells Fargo how far up the line
did this go great so I think that's what
the board David is still looking at at
Wells Fargo and our story was trying to
look at that as well this accountability
question that you have you know who knew
what who knew when and how what did they
do about it so the story that we looked
at was really about this generation of
executives that either could have known
or should have known and in some cases
we talked to people and they said look
they were told they were told that there
were suspicious numbers on the platform
here and they decided not to do anything
about it so do we have any instances
that you're aware of were senior people
specifically instructed lower people to
create fake accounts no that would be
the nuance we have no one we talked to
said we'd heard about or we saw a senior
manager who actively said to someone
please open a fake account but what
we're saying in what we talk to people
about was more that if they were told
hey these numbers are pretty suspicious
these are high I mean someone told us 42
debit accounts by a single banker in
Southern California nobody's said as a
manager hey that looks a little bit
fishy maybe I should look into that
perhaps this is made up perhaps it's
bogus if you were gonna have a
consultant come into this business and
have a dick around that have a look at
the hierarchy of how this company is
made up in terms of management etc and
in this monster piece that you've
written it's called the management army
the amount of branch managers there are
the amount of management above that
management above that can you just walk
us through that there why this is so
relevant
illustrates this point it's very
powerful yes exactly so on that chart
you will basically see that at the very
top of the banks so this is just within
the retail bank this is not talking
about the CEO the c-suite executives but
in the retail bank you've got three
regional bank executives we talked about
those people a lot in the story that's
John's to today and Lisa Stevens and
another as well and then you've got
these 12-lead regional presidents plus
the very senior regional presidents
there's about fifty four of those
together those are all the people at the
very top apparatus of the bank and then
beyond them you even have these senior
managers called the area manager is
about 120 of those and all of those
people of those top the bank told us
that they fired one
person five years yes one person whereas
they fired about 5300 lower level
employees branch managers bankers
tellers so our stories really focus on
that question why was no one else at the
top found to be accountable so is the
speculation this just never came up the
food chain I think I think it did and
our reporting it did come up the food
chain we have instances where people
were told about it by senior managers
telling their senior managers that
there's something wrong here or at least
you should question this and from our
investigation
you know those efforts were rebuffed now
I will say we did learn in our in our
investigation that the the company's
executives have identified certain
members of management we are not really
sure what that means maybe mid-level
maybe higher that they do have
identified for firing well that happened
when what happened we don't know why
haven't that high player already so what
they have been saying to us our sources
have said is that they want to give full
thrust to the investigation that the
board is doing before they make those
types of determinations they need their
cooperation in fact